That is the damaged Chernobyl nuclear reactor.
In 1986, after the accident it was encased in
the sarcophagus that you can see now
but it'sweathering and cracking and needs to be replaced
So they're building a new confinement structure
over here. They can't build it above the old
sarcophagus because the levels of radiation are
still too high
so they'll have to slide the wholestructure across.
It'll cost billions of dollars
and this structure will last a hundred years.
And that is only a temporary solution
because the half-life of uranium-238
is four and a half billion years. It's
the same as the lifetime of the Earth.
So in five billion years when all life has ceased
on this planet and the Sun is engulfing the Earth,
only half of the uranium which is still in
that sarcophagus will have decayed away.